moi je peux
et à midi
je
non
vva
je vous
il
bien mesdames messieurs les ministres
mesdames messieurs les ambassadeurs six
généraux mesdames messieurs je viens
donc vous rendre compte du sommet que
nous venons de tenir avant tout pour
remercier le secrétaire général y pour
justement la préparation de ces travaux
et la réunion qui s'est tenue
aujourd'hui qui a été ce que
j'appellerais un moment de clarification
stratégique
il commence nous avons encore beaucoup
de travail devant nous mais c'était une
étape importance importante que nous
avions souhaité à la fin de l'année 2019
en effet le contexte y appelait qui
était marqué d'une part en afin de
l'engagement en afghanistan ce qui est
un tournant pour l'alliance et la
nécessité d'en tirer les leçons
j'ai saisi d'ailleurs cette occasion
pour rendre hommage à celles et ceux qui
ont participé depuis 20 ans à cette
présence aux côtés du peuple afghan et
qui y ont perdu la vie et je veux ici
avoir une pensée pour les 90 français
qui sont tombés sur ce champ de bataille
et pour leurs familles et d'autre part
le contexte est aussi marquée par les
doutes et incertitudes qui ont émergé
ces dernières années en particulier en
raison des doutes sur l'engagement
américain de même que sur les objectifs
les principes et les règles de conduite
au sein de l'alliance
c'est ce qui m'avait conduit à
m'exprimer en fin d'année 2010 9 avec
une certaine clarté et au sommet de
londres en décembre 2019 de pouvoir
demander un rapport des sages et d'en
tirer les premières conclusions dans le
cadre de la déclaration qui aujourd'hui
est sorti de ce sommet qui va pouvoir
irriguer nos travaux dans les prochains
mois cette tarification se poursuivra
puisque nous avons commencé en européen
un travail dit de boussole stratégique
qui a été lancée par la présidence
allemande et qui va déboucher sous
présidence française
et nous aurons ensuite donc en 22 le
sommet de l'otan qui permettra de mettre
sur la table ce nouveau concept qui à ce
moment-là tirera toutes les conclusions
du rapport des sages
en tout cas cet agenda de vérification
je l'évoquais progresse
puisque nous avons très clairement
aujourd'hui afficher affirmer notre
volonté de revitaliser l'alliance
atlantique
non pas en revenant à des schémas du
passé mais je puis dire
retrouvant de la clarté je me félicite à
cet égard de l'expression d expression
du président biden à la fois lors du g7
est aujourd'hui comme d'ailleurs lors de
l'entretien bilatéral que nous avons pu
avoir il y a maintenant deux jours donc
à carbis b cette revitalisation de
l'alliance atlantique
c'est d'une part la réaffirmation de
l'attachement l'article 5 à la
solidarité entre alliés fondées sur nos
valeurs communes sur les principes
démocratiques et sur le respect du droit
international
cette réaffirmation est importante la ou
des ambiguïtés avait pu s'installer
c'est ensuite la volonté claire de
concertation étroite avec les alliés
européens pour conduire une double
approche de dissuasion et de dialogue
avec la russie et à ce titre pour nous
féliciter de la même manière du dialogue
qui s'est noué entre le président byden
et les européens ici présents en vue de
l' échange du 16 juin entre les
présidents byden et poutine et donc qui
marque cette prise en compte
je dirais et ce partenariat installé et
enfin par une approche partenariale et
non plus compétitives entre l'otan et
l'union européenne notamment sur les
défis posés par la chine et les menaces
émergentes que sont le cyber et l'espace
est à la fois le communiqué mais la
nature des discussions ont pu montrer
que cette volonté d'autonomie
stratégique de l'europe la construction
à la fois d'un discours d'une stratégie
de capacité que nous avons forgé ces
dernières années et bien une composante
qui renforce
l'otan est pas un concurrent et que
c'est une approche partenariale qu'il
faut prendre en compte là aussi pour
gérer notre propre voisinage
cette clarification est à mes yeux
essentielles et c'est le même esprit qui
a présidé d'ailleurs au débat la
discussion que j'ai pu avoir ce matin
avec le président erdogan que j'ai
longuement rencontré en tête à tête
avant le sommet
tarification sur le sujet de nos valeurs
et volonté aussi de trouver un chemin
utile en syrie et en libye je pourrais
revenir si vous avez des question j'ai
pu lors de cet entretien avec le
président erdogan également évoqué le
cas de notre compatriote fabien azoulay
et j'ai pu avoir il ya quelques instants
les réponses du président erdogan et
donc les les conditions d'un
transfèrement rapide avance qui je
l'espère nous permettront d'aboutir dans
les meilleurs délais mais la discussion
de ce matin a produit des résultats
d'ores et déjà utile ensuite au delà de
cet agenda de clarification qui
progresse les échanges avec les chefs
d'état ont également permis de la carte
et de l'exigence sur les points que la
france avait soulevé d'abord donc nos
valeurs ainsi p règles de conduite au
sein de l'otan nous avons acté ensemble
la réaffirmation de ces principes
inscrits dans le traité de l'atlantique
nord est un droit d'évocation des
différents camps le comportement d'un
allié pose question pour les intérêts de
sécurité des autres ce sujet au coeur du
rapport des sages au coeur évidemment
des discussions que nous avions fin 2019
est maintenant actée et c'est je pense
un élément important de nos règles de
vie commune
ensuite sur les missions et les
objectifs de l'alliance la discussion
d'aujourd'hui a permis véritablement
clarifier pour partie les choses d'abord
sur les définitions de l'ennemi je
l'évoqué d'ailleurs avec vous ou encore
hier pour celles et ceux qui
m'accompagnaient à carbis b est l'ennemi
est celui qui menace la souveraineté la
sécurité d'un déshabille et à ce titre
très clairement le terrorisme islamiste
menace nos valeurs et nos démocraties et
bien un ennemi identifiés et commun mais
les discussions ont permis aussi
d'avancer sur la clarification de notre
stratégie vis-à-vis de la russie qui
doit passer par un dialogue exigeant
dans un cadre robuste pour bâtir une
architecture de sécurité sur le
continent européen au travers en
particulier de la m
des armements celle ci s'est largement
des construites ces dernières années je
suis largement revenus et même si new
start est prolongé pour cinq ans la fin
du traité est finie la sortie de la
russie du traité ciel ouvert entre
autres ont acté la fin d'une
architecture de contrôle et de maîtrise
des armements sur le sol européen qui
implique de relancer une dynamique nous
avons pu en discuter chacun a fait
valoir
justement ces arguments la discussion
entre le président d'haydn et poutine
est un des éléments de celle ci mais
j'ai pu à cet égard réaffirmé la volonté
des européens d'être autour de la table
comme définissant aussi eux mêmes et
pour eux mêmes
les termes de ce contrôle des armements
pour ce qui concerne le sol européen
ceci implique aussi de nous donner les
moyens d'agir en premier lieu par les
efforts de défense nationale et donc de
ne pas d'espèces de ne pas nous
disperser dans des dépenses et des
missions est de faire aussi
je dirais de concentrer l'alliance sur
le coeur des missions qui sont les
siennes et donc à cet égard j'ai tenu à
clarifier plusieurs éléments l'alliance
doit vraiment être concentré sur le
coeur de ses missions les financements
que nous mettons à disposition sont des
financements pour partie commun mais
aussi nos financements nationaux et ils
sont essentiels pour la crédibilité
collective de l'alliance et c'est cette
grammaire qui doit continuer à présider
notre avoue la france je les rappelle
est un allié crédible et fiable et c'est
aussi pour cela que j'ai souhaité
d'abord rappelé ce principe mais
informer et expliquer à l'ensemble de
nos alliés les décisions stratégiques
que nous avons engagées au sel j'ai
l'occasion d'y revenir publiquement ces
derniers jours mais qui feront aussi
l'objet d'une concertation étroite entre
ministres mais aussi entre nos chefs
d'état-major des armées pour pouvoir
coordonner mais je les rappeler tous les
engagements que la france a pris à
l'égard de ses alliés comme de ses
partenaires au sel seront tenus cet
engagement de tarification comme je vous
le dis se poursuivra dans les prochains
mois
d'ici à la présidence française de
l'union européenne avec la boussole
stratégique puis au sommet d'octobre
2022 pour ce qui est du concept
stratégique et de sa révision
je vais maintenant répondre à vos
questions messieurs président bénédicte
tassart de airtel la chine est largement
évoquée dans le communiqué final
êtes vous d'accord pour dire que le
comportement de la chine est un défi
systémique comme il est écrit pour nous
européens sur la chine
je crois pouvoir dire je les rappelait
d'ailleurs qu'il ne faut pas confondre
les objectifs l'otan est une
organisation militaire le sujet de notre
rapport à la chine n'est pas que
militaire
le temps est une organisation pour
autant que la formule l'expliquent par
elle-même qui concerne l'atlantique nord
la chine a peu à voir avec l'atlantique
nord sauf incursion lorsqu'il y en a et
donc je pense qu'il est très important
de ne pas nous disperser et de ne pas
biaiser le rapport à la chine il est
beaucoup plus large que le sujet
militaire il est économique et les
stratégies qui les deux valeurs et les
technologiques et de ne pas divertir en
quelque sorte l'otan qui a déjà beaucoup
de défis quand on voit les sujets que
nous avons à traiter la question
terroriste
l' architecture de sécurité avec la
russie nos voisinages et je pense qu'il
faut embrasser la relation avec la chine
d'une manière beaucoup plus large comme
nous l'avons d'ailleurs fait lors du g7
et la chine j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire
la chine est une grande puissance avec
laquelle nous travaillons sur des sujets
mondiaux où nous avons son ensemble le
climat par exemple les questions de
financement du développement dans
lesquels nous avons réussi à avancer en
g20 sous l'initiative à acta ou de
financement des économies africaines et
donc il ya un agenda qui d'ailleurs un
produit des effets ces dernières heures
c'est ensuite un compétiteur sur le plan
économique dont nous attendons qu'il
respecte pleinement les règles qu'il a
librement consenti d'ailleurs de
respecter dans les principes en adhérant
en particulier
à l'organisation mondiale du commerce
est donc en respectant pleinement la
propriété intellectuelle et les règles
de réciprocité
et puis c'est une puissance avec
laquelle nous avons des désaccords de
valeur quand il s'agit du travail forcé
ou quand il s'agit des droits de l'homme
voilà le spectre de la relation avec la
chine
ensuite nous avons sur d'autres espaces
géographiques avec d'autres qui sont
autour de la cuisson qui ne sont pas
présents autour de la table une
stratégie c'est la stratégie indo
pacifique que j'ai eu l'occasion de
présenter au printemps 2010 8 car
ensuite été suivis par nos alliés
européens qui nous permet d'avancer et
préserver la liberté de la souveraineté
dans l'espace indo pacifique mais il
serait paradoxal que n'ayant à
l'exception des états unis qui on
regarde aussi côté pacifique n'ayant
aucune puissance indo pacifique autour
de la table nous puissions décider du
sort de ces derniers
je crois que c'est pas le bon cadre
voilà le le sujet chinois et donc je
pense que la formule est pour partie
juste mais je pense qu'elle ne doit pas
nous divertir du coeur des travaux de
l'otan
bonjour j'ai vraiment rêver de la fp au
cours de votre entretien avec le
président r de ram avez vous reçu des
assurances concrètes notamment sur le
retrait des troupes turques de libye et
par ailleurs avez vous eu des offres de
service que ce soit au g7 ou à l'otan
support de nouveaux pays pour participer
à la force et à kouba au sahel alors sur
la force takouba au sahel nous avons
comme vous le savez nous sommes dix
aujourd'hui a participé le ministre
affaires étrangères s'est rendu en
afrique ces derniers jours et nous avons
des discussions avec plusieurs
partenaires africains pour nous
rejoindre et dans des discussions que
j'ai eues avec le président rama foza
comme avec le président biden jeu
évidemment invité ces derniers à se
joindre à nous avec des effectifs même
limité donc les choses continuent et je
pense que il ya d'abord à organiser le
travail de précision de la manoeuvre
d'ici à la fin du mois de juin de
pouvoir ensuite l'exposé est de
consolider les nouveaux partenaires
comme vous lisez nous sommes déjà 10 et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui surtout nous
avons compte tenu du choix stratégique
qui est le nôtre et de la manoeuvre que
j'ai commencé à expliquer consolider ses
partenariats ce qui est pour moi une
chose très importante
j'ai bon espoir que nous continuons à
les élargir à la fois avec les
partenaires européens et alliés et
d'autre part avec plusieurs partenaires
africains ce qui est une composante
importante de la crédibilité de takouba
nous avons discuté du sujet libyen avec
le président erdogan et je crois que
nous avons trouvé des points de
convergence clair pour d'une part
préserver le cessez le feu
d'autre part tenir les objectifs
d'élections au 24 décembre prochain est
donc véritablement accompagné
aujourd'hui le gouvernement et président
les vice-présidents dans ce travail et
enfin pour allaiter travailler ensemble
au retrait des combattants étrangers et
mercenaires dans un premier temps et je
pense que c'est une avancée importante
nous avons ensemble actes et 10e
d'oeuvrer de concert
bonjour rim tasse de politico il paraît
qu'il ya eu un désaccord prononcé en
vous et votre ami mark rutte sur la
question qui vous tient à coeur
d'autonomie stratégiques européennes
pourriez vous nous en dire un peu plus
et est-ce que ça envoie un mauvais
message peut être si entre amis vous
n'arrivez pas à vous mettre d'accord
toujours sur ce sujet juste une
précision sur la turquie
est-ce que vous avez obtenu du président
verdone donc qu'il retire les
mercenaires syrien d'ici juillet le 1er
juillet merci sur première question il
appartient aux prêts au premier ministre
où te de clarifier sa pensée
j'ai noté qu'il y avait un accord
complet avec la chancelière merkel le
premier ministre draghi le président du
conseil sanchez le président en exercice
du conseil de l'union européenne premier
ministre portugais antonio costa donc je
pense qu'il y avait une quasi unanimité
autour de la table pour défendre
l'autonomie stratégique sa cohérence et
sa contribution à l'otan mais surtout il
ya la reconnaissance de celle-ci dans le
texte de la déclaration
et il a recommencé reconnaissance de
celle-ci par le secrétaire général de
l'otan et par le président by donne à la
fin ça me suffit pas ce que ça veut dire
que nous avons déjà réussi de peine à
passer cette étape qui était crucial
ensuite nous avons comme je les dis avec
le président erdogan actes et de
travailler ensemble à ceux à ce retrait
ça ne dépend pas en totalité de nous
deux mais je peux vous dire que le
président erdogan a confirmé dans un
entretien que nous avons eu ensemble sa
volonté que les mercenaires et milices
venant de l'étranger qui opèrent sur le
sol libyen puisse quitter celui-ci le
plus rapidement possible et sa volonté
d'y travailler ensemble et je souhaite
pouvoir et travailler avec lui dans les
prochaines semaines j'ai peut-être
prendre deux dernières questions
bonsoir monsieur le président mathieu
collège bfmtv deux questions où nous
posons avec ma consoeur ramard h 10 sur
la cybersécurité est de vous favorable à
l'utilisation de l'article 5 en cas de
cyberattaque ce qui pourrait avoir pour
conséquence d'isoler
la russie et la chine y que les
américains rendent régulièrement
responsables de ces attaques
et est ce que cette lutte contre les
cyber attaques a pour vocation de
protéger les citoyens dans le cadre du
multi latérale isme efficace que vous
défendez alors je pense qu'il faut être
il faut distinguer deux choses il faut
distinguer le cadre de l'article 5
est ce qu'il implique qui est temps en
effet aujourd'hui qui traite des
rapports au gouvernement à la
déstabilisation à la menace que qui se
posent contre l'intégrité d'un
gouvernement la sécurité d'un état
membre et donc il faudrait pour cela
qu'une cyber-attaque soit de nature à
être caractérisé comme une menace à
l'égard d'un pays où d'un gouvernement
je pense que la question se pose
aujourd'hui elle fait partie d'ailleurs
des travaux que nous avons engagées dans
le cadre de la clarification stratégique
pour ça que votre question est tout à
fait pertinente et elle sera clarifié
dans les prochains mois mais je veux
distinguer ici par rapport à la deuxième
la deuxième composante le fait que une
cyber attaque sur telle ou telle
personne sur telle ou telle structure ne
caractérise pas pour autant une attaque
cyber contre la souveraineté d'un pays
où ne menace pas forcément la sécurité
d'un pays et donc avant cela il nous
faut développer les voies et moyens de
nous protéger protéger nos concitoyens
nos structures les plus sensibles c'est
pour ça d'abord que nous avons dans le
cadre de notre revue stratégique et de
la loi de programmation militaire
développé des capacités défensives et
offensives que nous avons aussi
développé des capacités civiles pour
lutter contre les attaques cyber
capacité d'ailleurs que nous avons
activé ces derniers mois lorsque vous le
savez plusieurs hôpitaux ont été
attaqués et que nous avons besoin là
aussi de clarifier entre alliés nos
stratégies d'attribution et nos
stratégies de réponse
je le dis parce que bien souvent ce ne
sont pas des états qui attaquent ce sont
des acteurs privés et des entités
mafieuses et donc vous voyez bien que
nous rentrons dans un univers où les
critères d'attribution change ou le lien
avec les gouvernements n'est plus le
même et donc une série de clarifications
et de règles de conduite sont à définir
donc le sujet que vous évoquez est un
sujet pour l'otan qui est au coeur de la
mission et qui est vraiment en son coeur
de métier nous aurons à les clarifier
dans les prochains mois à côté de ça
nous avons développé des capacités
propres et donc nous y répondons et
enfin une partie de votre deuxième
question qui m'invitait à aller jusque
là partie de ce qu'on met derrière les
attaques cyber où les déstabilisations
est dans une zone que je qualifierais de
grease entre le civil et le militaire et
ne nuit pas forcément à la souveraineté
ou la sécurité d'un état mais peut le
déstabiliser dans son fonctionnement
courant dans la bonne information de ses
concitoyens dans sa vie démocratique et
donc pour ce faire nous sommes en train
de continuer à travailler à renforcer
notre cadre de contrôle et de protection
de nos règles démocratiques pour pouvoir
protéger la bonne information de nos
citoyens pouvoir nous protéger contre
ces attaques cyber en particulier en
temps de campagne électorale et de vie
démocratique et bâtir ce cadre il ya là
dessus un travail national qui est fait
et qui amènera des décisions qui ont
d'ailleurs déjà commencé avec une
implication particulière de l'anssi il
ya un travail au niveau européen qui est
porté par la commission qui est
transcrit dans les textes que celle ci a
commencé à porter qui va continuer de se
décliner et je vous rappelle la
proposition que la france la france a
fait sur ce sujet d'une agence de
protection de notre vie démocratique
contre les cyberattaques et en
particulier du travail
intergouvernemental que nous avons lancé
avec nos partenaires des états baltes
sur ce sujet et enfin il ya un travail
international qui l'a rejoint pour
partie l'agenda dit de christchurch et
de l'appel de christchurch où nous
souhaitons en effet protéger nos
concitoyens des discours de haine en
ligne etc mais aussi des manipulations
et de l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
par des structures publiques ou privées
qui cherchent à déstabiliser les
démocraties
je prends une dernière question bonjour
monsieur le président j'ai vite ambert
france télévisions au-delà des questions
internationales sur lesquels vous nous
dites avoir trouvé des convergences avec
le président r doan quel a été le
climat de cette rencontre sur le fond il
avait exprimé de grave désaccord avec la
politique menée en france notamment au
moment de la discussion sur la loi sur
le séparatisme et sur la forme il
n'avait été insultant à votre égard au
mois d'octobre dernier ce qui avait même
conduit au rappel de notre ambassadeur
en turquie s'en est il excusé qu'elle a
été donc le climat de cette rencontre
merci le champion le climat de cette
rencontre a été un climat apaisé et sans
qu'il y ait des excuses formulées ni
même que quelques excuses et tu être
demandée de partout d'autres il ya eu
une volonté claire de ré engagé un
travail ces derniers mois d'ailleurs ont
été marqués par plus de calme dans les
déclarations publiques et je m'en
félicite
mais nous avons l'un et l'autre actes et
qu'il était nécessaire compte tenu des
enjeux qui sont collectivement les
nôtres de tout faire pour pouvoir
travailler ensemble j'ai aussi apporté
des clarifications sur beaucoup de
sujets qui avaient pu être déformés
donné lieu à des malentendus ou des
attaques et en particulier sur la
question de l'islam
j'ai pu très clairement dire au
président erdogan que aujourd'hui la
politique de la france n'était pas de
s'attaquer à une religion qu en france
plusieurs millions de nos concitoyens
croix dans l'islam le pratiquent
quotidiennement
je dirais que ce n'est pas la sphère de
l'état que simplement ce qui leur est
demandé c'est de respecter absolument
les lois et les règles de la république
mais que le gouvernement de la france la
nation française se bat d'une part
contre toutes les formes de terrorisme y
compris le terrorisme islamiste et
d'autre part que nous avions en effet
renforcer notre politique de lutte
contre des groupes extrémistes qui
utilisaient des formes la religion pour
sortir certains de nos concitoyens de la
république et du bon respect de ses lois
je pense secteur efficace y ont été
nécessaires pour éviter les amalgames
qui avait donné lieu à une escalade
comme vous le dites de violence
d'embrasement pas simplement en turquie
d'ailleurs un dans aussi nombre de
régions où l'islam et le culte principal
et d'utilisation par certaines autres
puissent
en ce qu'ils ne voulaient pas forcément
du bien à la france est donc le
président erdogan je crois a entendu ces
clarifications et aussi manifesté le
fait que la sécurité de la france
la cohésion de sa société était pour lui
un point important la même manière que
je lui ai rappelé que le respect de
toutes les religions était un point
important pour la france c'est un chemin
sur lequel on peut construire des voies
de coopération et d action utile je
pense était important de d'avancé voilà
donc apaisement clarification et travail
concret sur les questions humanitaires
et l'accès humanitaire en syrie d'une
part et sur la libye dans les termes que
j'ai évoqué d'autre part est avancée
pour notre compatriote ne sut azoulay ce
dont je me félicite
voilà mesdames et messieurs je vais
regagner paris je vous remercie pour
votre attention
merci beaucoup bonne soirée